Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number and
that number is two one nine two.
David P. This is really funny.
Someone called in about on a live stream a
couple of months ago.
I recommended a particular ice cream.
This is a fantastic ice cream.
It's the brand is called.
It's either greatness or grader's.
Let me actually see.
I want to get it right.
Is it greatness, ice cream?
Greatness, this is not a sponsor.
OK.
Ice cream.
I've been a lifelong Cherry Garcia fan, but
I don't think it's actually that great.
I just didn't know of other cherry ice creams,
greatness, black cherry chocolate chunk, ice
cream.
Maybe the best ice cream I've ever had.
I mentioned it on the show.
All sorts of people now are obsessed with
this ice cream.
Take a listen to this.
Speaker 5: Hi, David.
I've been a member for Oh My God, over a year.
I want to tell you, I tried on your recommendation
craters, black cherry ice cream and it's excellent.
Cherry Garcia out of the water absolutely
beat something out of the water.
Thanks for everything you do.
I appreciate your time, your and everything
that you do for us.
I appreciate it.
Take care.
Speaker 1: Yesterday, I tried to get myself
some of this grader's black cherry chocolate
chip ice cream.
It's the one flavor that was gone from the
graters shelf.
I went to my grocery store and I went and
I said, Sir, where is the where's the ice
cream?
They said, Here it is, sir.
And there's a there was graders and they had
black raspberry and they had vanilla.
And then I just see an empty space and I look
at the tag and it says Black Cherry.
The black cherry is sold out.
I'm not taking responsibility for that.
I think I stumbled upon this as many other
people were stumbling upon it as well.
But I can't get my hands on the black cherry
ice cream.
So in the future, I'm not going to be mentioning
any products that I'm interested in buying
because it doesn't seem to be going super
well in terms of my ability to get them.
But fantastic ice cream, not a sponsor, just
good ice cream.
And I think like a dozen people have told
me, David, this this ice cream is amazing.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
The Fed plans to ban policy makers from owning
individual stocks, and this is an issue we've
been talking about for a long time.
The personal financial interests of members
of Congress number two Ron DeSantis, radical
Trumpian Florida Republican governor, governor
of Florida and Florida, which makes it even
crazier.
He's going to give five grand signing bonus
or wants to to unvaccinated police that are
quitting other police departments in other
states to come be cops in Florida.
OK.
And then lastly, Texas Lieutenant Governor
Dan Patrick, who offered to start handing
out rewards for people who find voter fraud.
He has finally paid out his first reward to
a Democrat for identifying identifying voter
fraud carried out by a Republican.
You love to see it.
You really love to see it.
All of those stories and more on today's bonus
show.
Sign up at join Pacman dot com.
You've got to spell it correctly.
I get email sometimes from people who say,
David, your membership website has a virus.
If you spell my name wrong, it will take you
to a different website that I don't know what's
on it.
OK, join Pacman Pack Amazon.com.
Sign up coupon code felony 21.
The code is such a big discount it should
be a felony, but it's legal.
OK, Felony 21 is the coupon code.
Sign up at Join Pacman dot com and we'll see
you on today's program.